>> Sean: THANKS FOR BEING WITH
US.
JOINING US NOW AUTHOR OF TRUMP'S
AMERICA, FORMER SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE NEWT GINGRICH.
ISN'T THAT NICE, 10 DAYS IN.
YOU GET A NICE FREE VACATION.
I DIDN'T KNOW THEY PAID FOR THE
PRIVATE JET AND THE MEALS AND
HOTEL AND PUT SUNTAN LOCATION ON
EACH OTHER.
IT'S NICE.
BONDING.
>> THEY DEVELOPED INTRICATE
RULES THAT ALLOW THEM TO DO WHAT
THEY WANT TO WHILE STILL
CLAIMING THEY ARE FOLLOWING THE
RULES.
THE PICTURE SHOWS YOU THE ROAD
MAP FOR THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT'S POSITION OUGHT
TO BE WE WON'T KICK THE CAN
FURTHER DOWN THE ROAD.
WE WILL GET IT SOLVED NOW.
THEY OUGHT TO CALL THE CONGRESS
IN AND SAY YOU HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO STAY HERE AND
FOCUS ON THIS.
SOMEBODY SUGGESTED THE RADICAL
IDEA THAT MAYBE THE CONGRESS
SHOULD NOT BE PAID DURING THE
SHUTDOWN SO IF THEY WENT THROUGH
THE SAME PROCESSESA THE FEDERAL
CIVIL SERVANTS WHO ARE NOT
GETTING PAID, MAYBE THAT WOULD
FOCUS THEIR ATTENTION.
THE PRESIDENT OUGHT TO SAY THIS
IS YOUR JOB.
YOU THE CONGRESS ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE SOLVING IT.
STAY HERE UNTIL YOU GET IT
SOLVED.
THAT'S THE STRONGEST POSITION.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
I UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN.
THERE WERE TIMES IN MY LIFE I
LIVED PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
I HAVE SYMPATHY FOR THE
FURLOUGHED EMPLOYEES.
A SOURCE TOLD ME THERE IS A
GROUP OF DEMOCRATS AND A GROUP
OF REPUBLICANS THAT MIGHT APPEAL
TO THE PRESIDENT TO GIVE THEM A
CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM AND IF THEY DON'T
GET IT DONE, HE WOULD DECLARE A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
WOULD YOU SUPPORT THAT?
>> NO.
I REALLY THINK THEY SHOULD FOCUS
ON THE CONGRESS DOING ITS JOB.
THE PRESIDENT DECLARING A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY IS
SIDESTEPPING THE CENTRAL PROBLEM
WHICH WE WILL HAVE FOR THE NEXT
2 YEARS WITH SPEAKER PELOSI.
YOU HAVE A HARD LINE LEFT WING
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHOSE RADICAL
WING IS WELL TO THE LEFT OF
BERNIE SANDERS.
THEY HAVE NO INTEREST IN
GOVERNING.
THEY HAVE NO INTEREST IN WORKING
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
FRANKLY, HE OUGHT TO LOOK AT THE
REAGAN PLAYBOOK.
WHEN I WAS A JUNIOR CONGRESSMAN
WE NEVER GOT TIP O'NEAL'S
SUPPORT.
WE GOT ABOUT A 3rd OF THE
DEMOCRATS WHO DECIDED THEY WOULD
VOTE FOR US.
BETWEEN THE REPUBLICANS AND THAT
ONE-THIRD, WE PASSED THINGS LIKE
THE 3 YEAR TAX CUTS.
IF YOU THOUGHT OF KEVIN McCARTHY
AS A POTENTIAL LEADER OF A
COALITION, 46 DEMOCRATIC
FRESHMAN WROTE A NOTE TO SPEAKER
PELOSI AND SAID THEY WANT TO
LETTING.
-- LEGISLATE.
GIVE THEM A CHANCE TO LEGISLATE.
THE REAGAN MODEL IS GO TO THE
COUNTRY TO FIND INDIVIDUAL
DEMOCRATS.
THE LEADERSHIP WILL NEVER CUT A
DEAL.
>> Sean: WHAT ABOUT THE SHUTDOWN
ASPECT?
INDEFINITE?
>> YES, BUT I WOULD URGE FRANKLY
THE LEADER McCARTY TO PUT
TOGETHER A DISCHARGE PETTICIAN
FOR THE HOUSE AND GET EVERY
REPUBLICAN TO SIGN IT.
WE WILL FUND THE SOUTHERN BORDER
AND WE ARE GOING TO FUND THE
GOVERNMENT AND WE ARE READY TO
VOTE TO DO BOTH.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS
IN THE LAST 4 DAYS WHO CAME OUT
AND SAID I COULD VOTE FOR THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
I COULD VOTE FOR THE WALL.
THERE IS A GROWING NUMBER UNDER
THE PRESSURE OF THIS WHOLE THING
WHO ARE SAY IS -- SAYING, LOOK,
I DON'T WANT TO BE UNREASONABLE.
THAT WILL COME AT THE BOTTOM.
LOOK AT THE PROCEDURE WHO FIND
40 OR 50 DEMOCRATS, COMBINE THEM
WITH THE REPUBLICANS AND GET
THINGS PASSED IN A BIPARTISAN
BASIS.
IN EFFECT, BEATING PELOSI AND
THE LEFT WING OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
IF RAISES A LOT OF QUESTIONS.
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOUR
STRATEGY.
I DON'T CARE WHICH WAY THE
PRESIDENT GETS THE MONEY
PERSONALLY.
A NATIONAL EMERGENCY OR STAYS
WITH THE SHUTDOWN OR FORCES THE
DEMOCRATS TO STEP UP AND DO
THEIR JOB.